[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Montag den Sport gibt's gleich von
Norbert Lehmer ein schön guten Abend
auch von mir schauen wir auf unsere
Themen Proteste und Gespräche die Bauern
blockieren große Teile von Berlin
ampelvertreter stellen ihn
Erleichterungen in
Aussicht krenhausreform und
Zukunftsängste vielen Krankenhäusern
droht die Insolvenz Städte und
Landkreise fordern mehr Geld vom
Bund und souveräne Siege und Zuversicht
die deutschen Handballer stehen in der
EM Hauptrunde und freuen sich auf den
Härtetest gegen Rekordweltmeister
Frankreich heute also der Abschluss der
Protestwoche der Landwirtinnen und
Landwirte bundesweit demonstrieren sie
seit Tagen bei der Abschlusskundgebung
ist auch Bundesfinanzminister Lindner
aufgetreten er verteidigte die geplanten
Subventionskürzungen aus Berlin Roman
leskova schon in der Nacht formiert sich
der Protest Trecker Lastwagen und
Lieferfahrzeuge rund um das
Regierungsviertel am Vormittag zählt die
Polizei dann 6000 Fahrzeuge im Zentrum
am Brandenburger Tor haben trotz der
Masse viele eher geringe Erwartungen
wenn man sich die Politik und die
Nachrichten aus der letzten Zeit
anschaut dann ist natürlich die
Zuversicht irgendwo etwas gehemmt wir
hoffen mal dass wir irgendwo halbwegsen
akzeptaaben Kompromiss irgendwo bekommen
wir haben die letzten Jahre so viele
Verbote und Auflagen bekommen dass es
für ein Betrieb einfach nur noch
existenzschädigend ist Spediteure
Handwerker Gastronomen unterstützen den
Protest auch sie fühlen sich
benachteiligt durch CO2 Bepreisung und
Mehrwertsteuererhöhung für die Bauern
geißelt ihr Präsident den
Kompromissvorschlag der Ampel er fordert
die Rücknahme der kompletten
Sparpläne sind iss bereit aber eines
lassen sie sich gesagt sein wir werden
wesentlich deutlich selbstbewusster
auftreten und selbstbewusster einfordern
was für Bauern berinnen wichtig ist
Applaus für den bauernpräsidenten
schmähufe und Beschimpfungen für den
Finanzminister der zeigt Verständnis für
die Proteste bleibt beim sparkompromiss
aber ich kann ihn
he hilfe versprechen aus dem
Bundeshaushalt aber wir können gemeinsam
dafür streiten dass sie wieder mehr
Freiheit und wieder mehr Vertrauen für
ihre Arbeit erhalten bis zum Mittag also
keine Annäherung der heutige Protest war
womöglich nicht der
letzte immerhin gab es heute ein
Gespräch der ampelfraktion mit
landwirtschaftsverbänden danach
kündigten die Spitzen von SPD grün und
FDP an ein Gesamt Paket zur Förderung
der Landwirtschaft beschließen zu wollen
der Bauernverband fordert weiter die
Subventionskürzungen beim Agrardiesel
zurückzunehmen Bern
Bentin während sich die Kundgebung am
Brandenburger Tor auflöst beginnen
Luftlinie 250 m entfernt im Reichstag
die politischen Gespräche die
ampelfaktionschefs Treffen Vertreter der
Bauernverbände und zeigen demonstrativ
Verständnis für den Protest wir haben
kein
erkenntnisdefizit wir haben ein
handlungsdefizit bei den
zukunftsherausforderungen der
Landwirtschaft Bürokratieabbau mehr Geld
durch eine sogenannte tierwohlabgabe all
das ist im Gespräch konkreter aber wird
es heute nicht bis zur Sommerpause so
das Versprechen wollen die
Regierungsfraktion für Entlastungen
sorgen wir glauben stark genug zu sein
als Parlament als Koalition in den
nächsten Wochen einen so klaren Katalog
auch zu unterbreiten die Vertreter der
Landwirtschaft wollen gemeinsam vor die
Kamera sie danken für das
Gesprächsangebot ihr ganz akutes Problem
aber bliebe auch nach dem Gespräch noch
bestehen in der eigentlichen Kernfrage
wie gehen wir in Sachen Agrardiesel
weiter haben wir das war vielleicht auch
nicht die Erwartung aber haben wir noch
keine Lösung die Bauernvertreter
berichten von jahrelang angestautem
Frust von Markt und Veränderungsdruck
von fehlender Verlässlichkeit und
mangelnder wertschätz das war
allerhöchste Zeit Landwirtschaft mit ins
Boot zu nehmen aber ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen wenn man so lange hinterm
Boot hergeschwommen ist dann braucht es
eine Menge an vertrauensbildender
Maßnahmen eine vertrauensbildende
Maßnahme das war wohl auch das Treffen
im Reichstag heute handfestes so die
Zusage soll jetzt
folgen jetzt soll also das große Ganze
angegangen werden Diana Zimmermann was
haben die genau
erreicht ja die Breite der Diskussion
tritt jetzt langsam in die gleichen
großen Fußstapfen wie das Ausmaß der
Proteste es geht ja schon länger nicht
nur um den agrardesel es geht eben um
die Strukturen der Landwirtschaft und es
geht auch um Anerkennung heute drehten
sich die politischen Gespräche eben um
Tierwohl um Bürokratieabbau auch um die
Macht der Discounter die bei der
Gestaltung der Lebensmittelpreise so
viel mitreden dass die Diskussion über
die Landwirtschaft jetzt in einen so
viel größeren Zusammenhang gestellt wird
das muss man als einen Erfolg der
Proteste sehen und die meisten Vertreter
der Landwirte haben das auch heute
anerkannt allerdings nicht ohne darauf
hinzuweisen dass es natürlich nur ein
erster Schritt gewesen sein kann vielen
Dank für diese Einordnung Diana
Zimmermann jetzt eine Bilanz des
vergangenen Jahres aus wirtschaftlicher
Sicht das ist für Deutschland nicht so
gut gelaufen das Brutto Inlandsprodukt
also die Summe aller Waren und
Dienstleistungen ist um 0,3% gesunken
2022 war es noch um
1,8% gestiegen Gründe für die Rezession
gibt es mehrere so war etwa der private
Konsum rückläufig auch der Staat gab
weniger aus und die Exporte gingen
zurück im Vergleich der großen
europäischen Wirtschaftsnationen liegt
Deutschland damit eher
hinten Kriege Inflation und Krisen haben
nach Berechnungen der
Entwicklungsorganisation oxfarm dafür
gesorgt dass 60% der Weltbevölkerung
weniger Einkommen zur Verfügung hatten
als früher die fünf reichsten Männer der
Welt hätten ihr Vermögen dagegen seit
2020 mehr als verdoppelt oxfarm fordert
eine Besteuerung hoher Vermögen von
Armut seinen Frauen und nicht weiße
Menschen überproportional
betroffen selten war ein Unwort des
Jahres so brisant und hochaktuell in
diesem Jahr kürte eine Jury aus
sprachenwissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern das Wort
Remigration das sei ein rechtsextremer
Kampfbegriff er stehe für
zwangsausweisungen oder
Massendeportationen von Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte so die Begründung
in der vergangenen Woche war ein Treffen
öffentlich geworden bei dem
Rechtsextremisten und AFD Politiker über
einen Plan für eine Remigration
gesprochen
hatten mehrere Apotheken sollen illegal
das coronamik paxlovid ins Ausland
weiterverkauft haben paxlovid war den
Apotheken kostenlos vom Staat für
Patienten und Patientinnen zur Verfügung
gestellt worden in Berlin laufen
Ermittlungen gegen die Betreiber von
sechs Apotheken so ein Sprecher der
Staatsanwaltschaft in Bayern gegen acht
Apotheken allein in Berlin wird von
einem Schaden in Höhe von 3 Millionen
Euro
ausgegangen die vom
Bundesgesundheitsminister geplante
krankenhausreform liegt derzeit auf Eis
der Bundesrat blockiert heute hat sich
Karl Lauterbach mit kommunalen
Spitzenverbänden in Berlin getroffen sie
fordern größere und schnellere
Milliardenhilfen von der Bundesregierung
um zu verhindern dass eine Reihe von
Kliniken pleite geht wie es aktuell um
die Reform bestellt ist zeigt ihn
britter
Spickermann im bayerischen tierschenreut
kämpfen Bevölkerung Ärzte und
Pflegepersonal um ihr Krankenhaus
Geburtshilfe und Chirurgie sollen
schließen die Notaufnahme sollen nur
noch tagsüber geöffnet sein das Land
Bayern und der Bund sollen helfen sonst
so die Angst drohe das komplette Aus für
ihre Klinik wir befürchten ganz einfach
dass ein wesentlicher Teil der Menschen
hier im Landkreis von einer ganz
normalen nichts Besonderes ganz normalen
Grundversorgung ausgeschlossen wird
kommunale Spitzenvertreter heute bei
Minister Lauterbach grundsätzlich sind
die Kommunen für die klinikreform
unterstützen dass sich Kliniken
spezialisieren müssen fürchten aber dass
viele kleine krankenh meist
rundumvsorger auf dem Land pleite gehen
wir erwarten jetzt schnelle Hilfe
schnelles Handeln kein weiteres zuwarten
und unbedingt Hilfe für die in Not
geratenen Häuser Milliarden Hilfen
sollen aber erst dann fließen wenn
Lauterbach sein Transparenzgesetz durch
den Bundesrat bekommt Lauterbach will
eine bundesweite klinikübersicht über
Behandlung und deren Qualität die Länder
bewerten das als Einmischung in ihre
Krankenhausplanung jetzt liegt die
gesamte klinikreform auf Eis
unstrittig ist wenn diese beiden
Reformen nicht kommen dann werden wir in
Deutschland ein
bedenkliches und auch größeres
unsystematisches krankenhaussterben
nicht abwenden können daher sind diese
Reformen unbedingt notwendig in tirschen
reut fordern die Bürgers Sicherheit für
ihren Klinikstandort was ist fragen Sie
sich wenn man im Notfall über 30 Minuten
zur nächsten Klinik braucht
tierschenreut ist nur ein Beispiel von
vielen in
Deutschland und wir schauen ins Ausland
im November wird in den USA ein neuer
Präsident gewählt Vorwahlen entscheiden
wer für die Republikaner gegen
Amtsinhaber Joe Biden antreten soll die
erste beginnt heute abend traditionell
in Iowa mit wahlverssammlung dem
sogenannten
kkasverfahren seit Monaten in Umfragen
vorn Ex-Präsident Donald Trump trotz
mehrerer gegen ihn laufenden
Gerichtsverfahren auf Platz 2 die
frühere UN-Botschafterin Nicki dahinter
Floridas Gouverneur rontis aus dem
winterlichen Iowa berichtet Emma
ten es ist frostig in Leon 1800
Einwohner in einem der ärmsten
Landkreise von Iowa im bers den der
Bärenhöhle will nur einer mit uns reden
John Wilson Veteran der us-mine
trumpanhänger macht die Grenze dicht
sonst zerbricht das Land wenn es nicht
schon zerbrochen
istlson sorgt sich um
Amerika eine riesen Angst er kann nicht
weiter ren muss ich erst einmal
fangen es ist einfach nicht mehr das
Land in dem ich aufgewachsen
bin bei den corkasis den
republikanischen Vorwahlen in Iowa
präsentieren sich alle Kandidaten als
Retter Amerikas Nicki Haley
exgouverneurin von South Carolina danach
unbotschafterin und Floridas Gouverneur
Ron
[Musik]
Santes never backdown niemals nachgeben
ein Song eigens geschrieben für desantis
er galt einmal als einzig
ernstzunehmender Konkurrent für Trump
könnte hier jedoch hinter hay auf Platz
3 landen ich will jemanden der nicht auf
Rache aus ist nicht auf
Bösartigkeiten auf Rache aus gemeint ist
der Mann auf den sie hier wachten bei
-30° Celsus er hat mit Abstand die
glühzen
Anhänger Donald Trump ist der einzige
der unser Land
viele Menschen hier in AA haben Angst
dass sich für sie wieder nichts ändert
dass sie von Problemen überwältigt
werden und deshalb wird hier wohl der
Mann gewinnen der ihnen Abhilfe für
alles verspricht wenn aber die Kälte
viele vom wählen abschreckt gibt es
vielleicht doch noch
Überraschung Wahlkampf in den USA das
ist ein Marathon der so ganz anders
läuft als bei uns wie das können Sie in
unserer ZDF heute App sehen mit allen
Terminen der Vorwahlen dann der Kandidat
K bis hin zur eigentlichen
Präsidentschaftswahl Anfang
November das Schicksal von mehr als 130
israelischen Geiseln in der Gewalt der
Hamas ist immer noch ungewiss nun haben
Angehörige der entführten erneut Berlin
besucht und auf eine Verhandlungslösung
gedrängt Deutschland sollle auf den
Vermittler Katar einwirken um alle
Geiseln frei zu bekommen die Angehörigen
wurden im Schloss belvue von
Bundespräsident Steinmeier empfangen
einige der Verschleppten haben die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft oder
familiäre Verbindungen mit
Deutschland und das Israel wird ein
palästinensischer Terroranschlag
gemeldet dabei wurde eine Frau getötet
mindestens 17 Menschen erlitten zum Teil
schwere Verletzungen die Attacke eignete
sich nördlich von Tel Aviv zwei Männer
aus Hebron fuhren mit einem gestohlenen
Auto gezielt Passanten an offenbar
stachen sie auch mit Messern auf ihre
Opfer ein die Palästinenser wurden
festgenommen
der ukrainische Präsident selenski ist
heute in der wo eingetroffen beim
Weltwirtschaftsforum mit einem klaren
Ziel mehr Unterstützung für sein Land
Erfolgsmeldungen sind da hilfreich sein
Militär teilt jetzt mit man habe zwei
für den Krieg bedeutsame russische
Flugzeuge zerstört darunter eine
fliegende
Kommandozentrale daheim hoffen die
Menschen auf mehr Hilfe angesichts von
Flucht und Not Anne Bröhl hat sich in
Lemberg im Westen des Landes
umgehört im Zentrum von Lemberg liegt
das Kaffee von Xenia
kleinos mit einem Rucksack kam sie hier
an aus berdjansk am asofschen Meer auch
ihre Mitarbeiterinnen sind
geflüchtete Leute die aus diesen jetzt
von Russland besetzten Gebieten gekommen
sind haben das Gefühl dass man ihnen die
Heimat genommen
hat man muss irgendwi we finden mit
diesem Verlust
umugehen
für viele Ukrainer ist Lemberg nicht nur
Durchgangsstation auf dem Weg ins
sichere Ausland seit Kriegsbeginn hat
die Region 350.000 Binnenflüchtlinge
aufgenommen natalas Familie ist aus
mariopol geflohen einmal im Monat kommt
sie zu einer lokalen
Hilfsorganisation wir haben nicht mehr
so viel Geld wie früher deshalb brauchen
wir Hilfe für Essen allgemeine Sachen
z.B
damenbindenast aller Ukrainer sind nach
unchätzungen auf Hilfe angewiesen die
ständigen Angriffe die Zerstörungen von
Häusern und Infrastruktur das betrifft
so viele und die Probleme werden
bleiben sobald die Kanonen Schweigen
werden die Leute noch mehr humanitäre
Hilfe brauchen denn es wird befreite
Territorien geben die Migration wird
zunehmen die Wohnungsfrage wird akuter
werden dass dieser Krieg schnell zu Ende
geht daran glaubt Xenia kleenos nicht
aber irgendwann hofft sie nach Hause zu
können nach berdjansk ans
Meer in Deutschland wäre grinderwig
irgendein kleines Dorf in Island zählt
der Ort in dem rund 3600 Menschen leben
schon zu den größeren Siedlungen zum
zweiten Mal innerhalb von vier Wochen
musste grinderwig nun evakuiert werden
weil ein Vulkan ausbruch die Menschen
dort bedroht und diesmal sind die
Lavaströme und seismische Aktivität noch
näher an bewohntem Gebiet Fachleute
befürchten sogar dass Magma unter dem
Zentrum fließen könnte CL Thomsen und
Henner Hebestreit Island kommt nicht
zuur Ruhe nach dem Vulkanausbruch im
Dezember öffnet sich die Erde nun direkt
am Ort grinderweg im Südwesten des
Inselstaates faszinierende Bilder für
Außenstehende für die Anwohner ein Drama
gestern waren sie nach einer Häufung von
Erdbeben evakuiert
worden hoffentlich könen Sie irgendwann
zurück aber die Situation ändert sich
eben ständig aber ich hoffe sehr für Sie
dass es mit der Rückkehr
klappt das Gelände ist weiträumig
gesperrt unter der schwarzen bereits
abgekühlten Oberfläche ist die Lava noch
flüssig und es droht Gefahr durch
giftige Gase Experten beurteilen die
Lage aus sicherer Entfernung vom
Helikopter aus während sich vulkanfans
und Journalisten an der Zugangsstraße
versammelt
haben heute morgen die gute Nachricht
die eine Erdspalte die sich innerhalb
des sicherheitswals befunden hat und der
gestern drei Häuser zum Opfer gefallen
sind die hat sich wohl beruhigt dort
Fließ keine neue Lava mehr raus und die
zweite Erdspalte außerhalb die ist etwa
mehrere hundert Meter von der Stadt
entfernt wie lange die Eruption andauern
wird ob für die Anwohner womöglich für
den Moment das Schlimmste schon
überstanden ist bleibt unklar für jene
die ihr Haus verloren haben ist das
Drama aber
schonuku war
set in unser neues Haus einziehen aber
das wird wohl nie
passieren seit d Jahren ist das
vulkansystem auf der Insel reanis auf
der auch der Flughafen liegt immer
wieder aktiv so wird dieser Ausbruch
wahrscheinlich nicht der letzte in der
Region
sein und jetzt kommen wir zur
handballheim EM norber die deutsche
Mannschaft gewinnt ja schon wieder ja
und hat sogar vorzeitig die Hauptrunde
erreicht wieder ein souveräner Erfolg
diesmal Z 25 gegen nordmazedonien
gestern Abend im zweiten Gruppenspiel ja
und wieder herausragend Spielmacher Juri
Knorr das Teamhotel der Deutschen in
Berlin vor anderthalb Stunden
videositzung vor der Partie morgen gegen
Rekordweltmeister Frankreich viel wird
auch daavon Juri Knor abhängen Z Tore
gegen nordmazedonien und Auszeichnung
zum besten Spieler des Spiels Juri hat
bisschen Kritik bekommen in der Liga
dass er nicht ganz so gut ist wie im
letzten Jahr und ich habe versucht das
so erklären dass er einfach bisschen
anders spielt und heute hat er sehr
gutes Spiel gemacht er wird auch langsam
besser in Abwehr ebenfalls überzeugend
knorzimmerkollege David spet der Sieg
nie gefährdet schon zur Pause führt das
dhbteam mit fünf Treffern das schönste
Tor des Abends ein herrlich
herausgespielter campertrick Knorr auf
Köster ob sie auch die Franzosen so
verzaubern
werden max Eber wird nach
übereinstimmenden Medienberichten neuer
Sport V stand bei Bayern München und
damit Nachfolger von Hassan sali hamiic
der 50-Jährige war zuvor Manager bei
Gladbach und Leipzig zu den Australian
Open da haben heute Laura Siegemund und
Tatjana Maria ihre erstrunden Einzel
gewonnen ja und bei den Männern da
siegte Jan Lennard struf in einem
epischen
fünfsatzkmi das Publikum steht komplett
hinter dem Australier rinky hitchikat
der peitscht die Zuschauer an und sorgt
für megga Stimmung im Match gegen Jan
Lennard Struff doch den ersten Matchball
hat die deutsche Nummer 2 den kann der
33jährige zwar noch nicht nutzen doch
nach einem rückhandfehler des
Australiers gewinnt struf nach fast 4
Stunden Spielzeit 3:6 6:3 6:2 6 Z7 und
7:6 die drei weiteren dtbpis Jannik
hanfmann Maximilian Matera und Daniel
Altmeier sind dagegen in der ersten
Runde
ausgeschieden ja und morgen kommt
definitiv noch ein deutscher weiter
Alexander spielt gegen Dominik Köpfer
danke schön das Wetter noch morgen
entspannt sich die Lage erstmal bevor
Mittwoch durch Schnee und Eisregen neue
Gefahren drohen mehr dazu gleich von
Katja hornfer dunia Hayali begrüßt sie
um
21:45 Uhr zum heutejournal und morgen
übernimmt hier Barbara halweg auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
guten Abend mit Schnee und Glätte hat
diese Woche gestartet und das zugehörige
tief zieht weiter nach Osten mit diesen
Schneeschauern haben wir es jetzt auch
am Abend und in der Nacht zu tun die
ziehen über den Norden und Nordosten
hinweg sonst ist es zum Teil auch mal
trocken und die Temperaturen sinken auf
1° an der Nordsee und bis -11° über
Schnee am Alpenrand die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen um den
Gefrierpunkt am mildesten wird's an der
nordseküste mit 4° und auch morgen
gibt's noch einige Schneeschauer hier im
Norden sonst wird das ein freundlicher
Dienstag mit viel Sonnenschein im
Südwesten das ändert sich dann aber in
der Nacht zu Mittwoch und Mittwoch über
Tag ziehen von Südwesten Regen Eisregen
und Schnee auf und es kann besonders im
Westen über Stunden anhalten schneien
und diesen gefährlichen Glatteisregen
geben also vermeidbare Wege sollten Sie
Unterlassen von allen le bekommen Sie im
Norden nichts mit da ist der Mittwoch
recht freundlich und im Südwesten wird
es markant milder da steigen die
Temperaturen am Mittwoch bis 11° am
Donnerstag ziehen Schnee und Regen dann
weiter in Richtung Süden der Freitag
wird freundlicher bei -2 bis + 4° guten
Abend